many websites now allow for two-step
authentication so my question is just
changing carriers but keeping your same
cell phone number break this process in
any way since different carriers handle
SMS in different ways Charlie that's
actually a question I'd never thought of
before but first let me explain what
two-factor authentication is for some of
our viewers that might be unfamiliar
2-step verification or authentication is
a special security feature that many web
services including Google Facebook
Twitter Yahoo and others offer in
addition to typing in your password like
you normally do there's a second
confirmation that comes in the form of a
text message when enabled you type in
your password like you normally do and
then the company text messages you a
special code to input in this time of
lots of security breaches and hacks it's
a really good idea to start using you
can look for it under the security
settings of many of these popular
services the good news for you Charlie
is these services just recognize the
phone number not the carriers so
changing carriers should not break the
process you should feel confident in
deciding to switch to another carrier
but keep that same number if you're
really worried you can disable the
two-factor authentication then switch to
the other carrier and then re-enable it
to make sure you get the code it was a
great question and we want to hear more
like it you can send them to us anywhere
Facebook Twitter Google+ Instagram vine
myspace just use the hashtag ask wsj d